[Musique]
alors cette semaine aussi 17 mai dans
plein d'autres salles en france
on va essayer de se faire un petit peu
de bien ces temps on va dire légèrement
morose et on va partir avec antoinette
dans les cévennes donc c'est un long
métrage de caroline signal qui est un
très bonne surprise en cette rentrée
dans les cinémas assez morose puisque
plein de films vous le savez
probablement ont été déprogrammés
notamment des gros films américains et
c'est un film art et essai français donc
avec laure calamy qui est une jeune
actrice qui monte qui monte qui monte
benjamin lavernhe qui est un comédien
que vous avez déjà vu dans plusieurs
films qui est excellent notamment dans
le sens de la fête et celui qui joue le
marié et voilà et donc antoinette va
partir sur les traces de benjamin donc
qu'ils aient les autres courses en
allemand dans le film mais qui ne peut
plus partir au dernier moment en
vacances avec elle pour essayer de le
retrouver dans les magnifiques cévennes
que vous allez travers traverser avec
elle accompagné d'un âne donc très joli
film à découvrir dans nos salles cette
semaine
[Musique]